soit on reçoit on reçoit voilà dans un
instant on va recevoir un des plus
grands rappeurs
voilà un pote un ami je vous demander de
l'accueillir ce soir il est avec nous un
peu de ce nom pour lui
[Applaudissements]
laissez moi j'ai pris je suis beau bal
masqué bah évidemment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
envoyez-moi l'invité le vrai allez vite
en voyant l invité
[Applaudissements]
c'est là la caméra fait le fait trop
fait couver ouais gros samaté branche
c'est l'autre truc qu'il faut faire
ainsi donc on travaille demande de vous
arrêter là du rameau de l'alim tu me
touches pas l'épaule est bonne et les
ménages valérie mais d'ajuster 40 ans de
carrière allait bartois barre toi
balladur
bon
[Applaudissements]
z qui je suis au bar mitsva c'est le
seul il s'est barré tout seul